[Music]
dan is in portland oregon hi dan
welcome to the ramsay show hi dave
uh thank you christy for taking my call
i live
in a nice condo complex in portland and
i sit on the
hoa board about three years ago
we had a step dad
who is a kind of a prominent attorney in
the area decided to buy
one of the condos for his two
stepdaughters who
shortly thereafter decided to turn the
condo into a meth lab
oh god so
basically what occurred is about two
months before
hazmat and the drug introduction team
raided the location uh stepdad did a
quick claim deed handing it over to the
two step-daughters
so now since then the unit's been closed
up
we had the locks changed on it hazmat
took the
uh toxic chemicals out of the location
however they left everything else in
there all the garbage the needles the
syringes i've got the pictures
it's horrific on the inside of this
condo and they're nice condos
so we've been trying to figure out how
do we go about
trying to get this unit cleaned up do we
take it out of our hoa funds
and clean it up and put it under a lien
uh
can you go back on a quick claim deed
and challenge it
or um currently the the
courts are backed up on foreclosures
and and putting it up for auction so we
figure it's another year or two before
it'll even come up for auction we don't
want to let this unit sit
and draw rats and and any other vermin
uh that may come in um it's about 10 000
own and the property taxes 6 000 and the
hoa
uh fees that we have a lien on but we
can't get the state or the city
to come in and clean it up so oh do you
know do you have any idea what to owe on
the condo
uh the skip yet ep cash for it
okay and the two the the two brats are
in jail
uh not to be found they're gone
where are they i mean we need to find
them nobody nobody knows
nobody knows we've had our attorney try
to locate him
and can't be found so talk to stepdad
um we have not talked to stepdad
because he did a quick plan deed that's
why i'm asking no i'm just trying to
find them i want
i just want to make them an offer and
buy the condo
so if we could go to them and say we'll
buy it for
20 000 yeah we'll give you money
and then i mean and you'd have to get
the i don't know if the condo
association
is authorized to do that with condo fees
i doubt it
uh you're not exactly authorized to
you're not you're a non-profit you're
not authorized to do investing on behalf
of the hoa
uh right but but uh dude
something you gotta do something how
it's a condo worth if it didn't have all
this crap going on
so i bought my condo three years ago for
uh 225 and yeah they're going for
over 300. so scratch around find
somebody's got 40 grand and find these
brats and offer them 40 grand and then
let's clean and let the investor clean
the mess up
you you don't own the condo i i mean
you're gonna have to contact the
attorney that represents your hoa
but in my opinion you don't need to be
going in that thing at all
unless you have hoa documents that allow
you to break and enter
and clean up a mess and put a lien
against it on your on the behalf of the
hoa
i don't you could get yourself in a real
mess here plus it's dangerous
you don't want to you don't want to mess
with a dadgum meth lab man that's a
that's a
explosion looking for a place to happen
exactly exactly and even though they
took the toxic chemicals out
they left all the garbage and everything
that the
let me tell you if they baked meth in
there the toxic chemicals are not gone
they're in the wall
you're gonna have to strip that thing
down somebody's gonna strip that thing
down to the studs
if it was a house out in the country we
would throw dynamite in the middle of it
and call the fire department let them
practice on it
right it's a disaster to get that mess
out of there the fumes go into
everything
it's baked into the walls now it's a
problem man i mean somebody but if you
can buy it for 50 grand spend another
100 on it
you're still in there way under as an
investor if you know what how to do the
recidivism work on the thing or the
that's not what it's called but anyway
clean the mess up no and i'm talking
about the baked in mess it's like
man it's it's almost as bad as cat smell
i mean it's almost impossible to get it
out of there
so yeah you got wow i i would hesitate
to start
acting on behalf of the hoa without
legal counsel
right right and we're trying to figure
this out how do we get this thing
cleaned up
rather than let it set yeah i think you
asked your lawyer about that
uh but in the meantime for on a
practical level if you can get the
ownership transferred and get an
investor to come in
and clean the mess and do the full
hazmat strip down
on a meth lab good god and um
yeah it's i mean these things these
people die because the whole house
explodes sometimes is there a liability
on the condos on either side
it's potential i mean the hoa you know
has
they have uh the hoa would have
structural insurance on all the condos
but yeah it's it's a it's a problem yeah
so i i would be looking for the brats
and get you know offer them some money
with an investor in tow
and let that investor come in and clean
the mess up and
or meantime i'd be checking with my
lawyer at that represents the hoa you
need legal counsel on this hoa be
careful
because everything you walk in there and
touch i have no idea what you're getting
into
it's dangerous stuff this is the ramsey
show